digit la façade de ce collège allait
elle est magnifique aujourd'hui elle est
très bien restauré mais pourtant il ya
quelques années ce n'était qu'une ruine
absolument quand stéphane bern la
visiter en fin 2012 sartenais au
département qui souhaitait vendre les
deux batibouw puisqu'il ya deux
bâtiments sur le site et c'était
vraiment très très délabré c'était a
restaurés d'urgence avant que l'un d'eux
se dégrade davantage
il ya eu trois ans de travaux pour en
arriver là
régis et l uniforme des élèves du
collège voilà c'est d'uniformes des
enfants qui suivent leur scolarité dans
les écoles royale militaire est
d'ailleurs cette année petit quand il a
fini ici à voir un élève très connue
puisque napoléon bonaparte avait obtenu
sa bourse et son entrée pour faire ses
études militaires ici et puis finalement
son papa a préféré l'école de brienne on
est devant le mobilier d'une salle de
classe
c'est assez traditionnel finalement on
peut penser à leur enseignement qui
était fait comme les élèves de
maintenant avec de la musique des
langues étrangères des mathématiques de
la littérature
mais tout cela dans un but également
militaire donc avec également des décors
pour la manipulation des armes
et les jardins qui appartiennent
également à la propriété se visite aussi
oui tout à fait et viennent d'être
refaits également parce qu'évidemment
après 4 en chantier desjardins était
très délabré aussi et maintenant il faut
attendre que ça pousse mais le chantier
n'est pas complètement terminée
puisqu'il ya encore des choses à
améliorer c'est toujours eux évolutif
pascal de soi on sait comment se porte
le tourisme dans le perche qui vient
visiter quoi alors le perche est
typiquement une région de court séjour
c'est à dire ce sont des personnes qui
vont venir sur deux trois quatre jours
sans famille soit chez des amis pour
venir se reposer et ils viennent
chercher une quiétude et un beau paysage
et quelque chose d'apaisant pour se
reposer et se ressourcer c'est vraiment
un tourisme de ressourcement justement
il ya beaucoup de touristes d'europe du
nord horizons et prix de nature tout à
fait normal parce que le tourisme
dentaire chez vraiment un tourisme de
nature de par toutes les provenances que
l'on peut faire de par son paysage très
riche
l'équipe bay caudines vous avez admiré
cette belle colline très arrondi les
chemins entre le paysage bocager
d'épaisses forêts domaniales on a 400
ray domaniale ouverte
on peut aller se promener et on sait
bien que les touristes de l'europe du
nord sont très féru de tout ce qui est
du tourisme de nature
alors le père géographiquement s'étend
sur 4 départements il ya l'orne l'eure
et loire la sarthe loir et cher vous
représentez le parc naturel du perche
est-ce que politiquement c'est difficile
parfois de composer avec toutes ces
collectivités locales je dirais
administrativement plutôt parce que donc
ça veut dire deux départements
principaux différends des régions
différentes chacun avec sa politique de
tourisme il faut composer
il faut aller au delà de tous ces
blocages administratifs
pour donner un élan et une dynamique sur
le tourisme notamment mais entre autres
et sur d'autres sujets clés
l'environnement et la biodiversité